if you want to understand how bad things
are in this country right now let me
show you this story from the hill why
Contraband eggs are piling up at the U.S
Mexico border that's right ladies and
gentlemen it's so bad that people are
trying to smuggle chicken eggs in from
Mexico and before you all go and say to
him the reason there's an egg shortage
is because of the avian flu let me just
remind you that the avian flu doesn't
know what a border is it's not like at
the southern borders a bunch of chickens
dying and then running the other side is
a bunch of chickens living there are
chickens in Mexico running right on the
other side of the Border laying eggs but
for some reason people have to smuggle
them in to the country because we don't
have chickens laying eggs 10 miles away
no it's because inflation and policy and
policies implemented by Biden and
Democrats have been bad now don't get me
wrong even flu has been devastating it's
resulted in shortages it's a
contributing factor but people would not
be smuggling eggs into the country if it
were not for other issues so uh what do
you think your I'll I'll say it again
because I said at the beginning of the
show but for those are just watching
this segment if you went back to 2020
right before the election and warned
your family members if you vote for Joe
Biden I swear in two years people will
be smuggling eggs into this country from
Mexico in desperation
what do you think they'd have said to
you
you're crazy simply put yeah yeah that's
a little far-fetched but then what I'm
thinking about is I think that what
there is happening is they can sell
these eggs in Mexico for you know 19
cents but if they take them across the
border they're probably getting like a
dollar fifty per egg why so it's like a
smuggling tactic like you're a problem
you are correct oh inflation and uh
subsidy uh government subsidy inflation
corporate collusion like their price
setting probably they're not supposed to
be but I have a feeling that they are
that they're like we're not going to go
any lower
USDA or whoever is in charge of the egg
sales we're setting the price at you
know 6.99 and we'll track it with
inflation or something like that
remember those videos from the pandemic
of Dairy Farmers pouring out gallons and
gallons of milk because they had the
product but the supply chain was so
destroyed that they couldn't get it to
the store but then that meant that we
were
further uh we were creating more chaos
because then they didn't have milk
that's sort of what the egg issue
reminds me of like these are the results
of the administration we are currently
under and well the milk boring stuff
happened to Trump but these were
Democrat Governors that were going crazy
on shutting down their states Rhonda
Santos of course I think I think he shut
down early on and then reopened much
earlier than anybody else South Dakota I
think never shut down so it was
certainly under the Trump Administration
we were seeing all of this stuff and
Trump was the one who proposed shutting
down for a couple weeks but then when it
became apparent they were never going to
allow it to reopen and Trump was like
look I can't do anything it's a state
level issue you know I guess the
challenges sorry that means that Biden
came into this aware of this issue and
has not been able to fix it I mean we're
three years out from the onset of the
pandemic right and nothing has gotten
better that's gotten worse that should
be alarming to all of my family members
that voted for Biden but I feel like
they'll buy the avian flu thing they'll
say oh
we have to do we've got to keep flocks
separate or something the lockdown was
bad for a lot of reasons like people
weren't working but in terms of the raw
economic numbers yeah it's it's actually
worse like the aftermath of those
policies has made things tremendously
worse and the Biden Administration over
the past it's been two years has not
fixed this when you look at the the
economic numbers there's graphs on
inflation wages you can see Biden get
elected executive orders hit and then
all of a sudden wages drop all of a
sudden inflation skyrockets that is not
an issue of uh uh I should say that is
specifically an issue of bind
Administration policy that they want to
argue that no no it was Trump that did
that because what happens with the Trump
campaign they neck policies and then it
takes a year to come in and Biden says I
came in and it was like this not true
because you can actually see the
inversion happen overnight when he
enacts these these executive orders so
yeah this is what you get with a Joe
Biden you get War I mean mean think
about this under Donald Trump we had the
Abraham Accords we had Isis getting
crushed he was negotiating peace with
North Korea setting a timeline for
getting out of out of Afghanistan trying
to get our troops out of Syria and under
Joe Biden we are on the brink of World
War III inflation is at record highs
going back to World War II we've got
people desperately trying to smuggle
eggs from Mexico I I am not look I'll
give Joe Biden credit if if he deserves
credit I try to
and Donald Trump deserves criticism when
he deserves it and I will I will make
sure you know we've talked about the
things that he did that were not good
ramping up drone strikes we could argue
that all day and night Luke obviously
would come and do it but it is I I don't
see how an objective human being who
reads the news sits here and says Trump
was worse and Trump was a hundred folds
better than where we're at right now I'm
not going to blame Biden or Trump for
the pandemic but certainly after two
years of the pandemic being over or I
should say him coming in when we're on
the back end of it things should have
dramatically improved but you know the
problem is Joe Biden comes in he shuts
down Keystone he shuts down Keystone
Pipeline he shuts down uh oil and gas
leases on federal lands and then some
then you've got other Democrat
politicians and governors they want to
ban uh cars or gas cars they are making
policy for ideological reasons that make
it worse for everybody else Donald Trump
was enacting economic populist policy
that was making things better for the
American people that's the difference
I guess the the challenge in comparing
Joe Biden's Administration and trumps is
that there's no control like there were
different time periods of History so the
Federal Reserve inflation were what
everything was like a 26 trillion maybe
when Trump came in or something like
that now it's a 33 trillion or 20 some
numbers like that but they basically
knocked the value of the dollar down
from a dollar to 89 cents or some stupid
thing like that so that's a natural
thing that is not is irrelevant to the
Presidents although you could argue that
this President encouraged the printing
it was Congress that did it and Congress
passed the bill uh I think that if
neither of them shattered the Federal
Reserve and created a new monetary
system so I blame them both
personally I think both those guys just
kicked are kicking the can down well
let's let's let's do this okay I mean
Trump and DeSantis are going at it but
who else is who else do we have are
there any other Republican I mean Nikki
Haley she's gonna run Kanye West yeah
John Bolton yeah he did yeah he said
he's running well this is what they said
he told me last I've seen him or last we
talked everybody said yeah he told you
Shane and I asked Shane again well we
did I think we talked about it on the
show he talked about on the show then
Shane I asked Shane he was like yeah
he's definitely running so if he's
definitely running Kanye West all the
way I mean what the heck as a republican
I don't know it's like so ridiculous to
put a famous musician in his president
but like Ronald Reagan Donald Trump was
just an actor I mean he was like a
famous actor Ronald Reagan Ronald Reagan
was a famous actor what was what was the
joke from Back to the Future
they say like Ronald Reagan's present
like the actor like get out of here I
mean ASA Hutchins and from Arkansas has
rumored is like potentially exploring
Larry Hogan the Republican former
Republican governor of Maryland says
that he is considering you hear all
these names but
I don't know who actually wants to go
against Trump and we've talked about
this
Trump endorsed so many people and from
what I remember had a pro like decent
success rate with the people he endorsed
so if you decide now I'm going to go
against Trump what does that look like
if he wins for the next two for six
years for you I mean you might isolate
the people who voted who elected you
into office so it's a really tricky game
I just don't think the Republican party
is sure how to navigate this and if we
had more fire behind the Trump campaign
it might become more clear right there
might be people who are considering
running Who would know no I just can't
handle this I think you got to be crazy
to want to be involved in political
office at all yeah or I got to be honest
public life any of that stuff has
varying degrees of insanity that you
need to be in order to want to be
involved in any of this like I don't
even know why you guys are on this show
you guys are insane right you got to
spread the message Man gotta proliferate
God's energy that's what it's all about
I mean it's a sacrifice you have to make
being famous to get this word out I
think I would go to Congress and talk to
the people and give them ideas and
listen to everyone I get to know every
one of them there's like 400 of them and
that's another problem tomorrow it's
another problem with Congress is it's
too big and I don't think they own they
don't know each other so they're sitting
in a big room with people they don't
even know like you got to know that guy
if you want to if you want to congress
with him I mean it's a verb means to
move together should I not have said
that I mean I think you already did oh
yeah we're gonna we're gonna be at the
Capitol tomorrow yeah yeah we'll be
interviewing thank God we have that
opportunity you say what you want um but
I agree with you and that I don't want
the title I'm not seeking the power of
the title like look at my badge everyone
now like if I'm doing it right then my
actions will speak for themselves and I
don't think Ben Franklin he didn't need
office he didn't need a roll office he
was there to help all the other ones
like I I could kind of go that route but
I will also take the presidency if it's
up for grabs and no one's gonna do it
right I think it's got to be would you
manage
whose campaign would you manage yes for
sure
let's do it maybe maybe VP Trump
Crossland 2020 or Kanye Crossing I've
been trying to get a hold of Kanye I
messaged Milo but I think Milo's just
like haha you you fool
also too when you look at the other side
I think that's going to be crazy right
because these guys like the Dems don't
want Biden again his record's been
abysmal but I don't want to Biden again
right of course of course but I mean who
is it going to be on that side I think
is interesting too I think definitely
Gavin Newsom is going to be a strong
Contender
um but yeah going back to just how awful
Biden's records been I mean we've had
5.5 million people across the border
since his inauguration and in 2022 he
sent 50 billion to Ukraine so the state
of the union is that it sucks yeah and
people don't want another Biden
presidency well I remember last year's
State of the Union was actually just a
campaign speech he called it the state
of the union and quote but it was just
talking about what he's going to do so
it's going to be it's the same thing was
it Jimmy Carter who's the only one who
gave up there was like the state of the
union is not good I can't remember which
president but there's one who was like
he came right out of the gate and was
like look I'm unhappy I don't like it
but I just don't think there's anything
Biden could say tonight that would win
over people who feel like they are
struggling because of him and I think
that there are enough left like centers
and left-leaning people in the U.S who
feel like perhaps they were sold a bad
bill of goods here and he is not coming
to save them why would they put him in
office again thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time